On Saturday, August 2,
at around 9:30pm,
Iuvenilla was born.
While I do have a daughter,
her name isn’t Iuvenilla,
and she wasn't born on August 2.
This was a graffito,
a message written
by a proud papa or a proud mama,
on the walls of ancient Pompeii
nearly 2,000 years ago.
And while we might send
a birth announcement
or take to social media,
this Pompeiian took to the walls
to exclaim their happy news
and even accompanied the message
with a drawing
of little Iuvenilla herself.
The reason why we have this graffito
and thousands like them
was the destructive and deadly eruption
of Mount Vesuvius in 79 AD.
This volcanic eruption preserved
this graffito for us today.
We might wonder what happened
to little Iuvenilla,
likely only a few weeks old
when the eruption happened.
I hope she was able to escape
with her family as many did.
I've been interested
in the Romans since I was little
and Pompeii, especially,
as I share my birthday with the eruption
of Mount Vesuvius on August 24.
I started learning Latin in high school,
and while I enjoyed the language
and enjoyed learning about the Romans,
I couldn't connect
with the stories of Julius Caesar
or even the love poetry of Ovid.
I wanted to know what were ordinary
Romans doing and thinking.
And in college, I was introduced
to Latin graffiti.
Now for the first time I could hear
the thoughts and words of ordinary Romans.
When I went to Pompeii,
I could put myself in their sandals
standing next to a column,
imagining the messages
they might write to one another.
Line graffiti allow us to hear
the thoughts and words of ordinary people
who lived in antiquity.
But I believe by studying Roman graffiti,
we can learn a lot more
about what makes us human
and a lot more about ourselves too.
Now, when you hear the word graffiti,
you're probably imagining spray-painted
messages in urban centers,
bathroom graffiti or maybe
graffiti artists like Banksy.
But ancient graffiti were much different
than modern graffiti.
Modern graffiti are typically illegal
or at least taboo in cities today.
Ancient graffiti were welcome
or even permitted.
They appear in nearly
every space in the ancient city:
temples, tombs, bars, public spaces
and even inside homes.
Almost nothing was off limits.
Modern graffiti are typically
written in spray paint
or scratched into a surface
like a bathroom stall.
Ancient graffiti were typically
scratched into the wall plaster
using a sharp instrument
like a stylus or a nail.
In fact, our English word "graffiti" comes
from the Italian word meaning "scratched"
and was coined when 19th century
archaeologists first encountered
the scratched graffiti of Pompeii.
Ancient graffiti were written
by a wide variety of people,
and they're some of our best evidence
for people marginalized
from the literary record,
like women and the enslaved.
Now the reason why the Pompeiians
wrote so many graffiti
is they didn't have access
to inexpensive writing tools like paper.
So they took to the walls to send
messages to one another,
record observations
or even record things using tally marks
in the same way we might use scrap paper,
our phones or even social media.
Now on the screen now are two
of the most famous graffiti from Pompeii.
Unfortunately, both of them
don't survive for us today,
but drawings made
at the time of their excavation
allow us to see
what they once looked like.
The one on the top says,
"This is the labyrinth,
the Minotaur lives here,"
and is accompanied by a drawing
of a labyrinth from mythology.
This graffito was written
inside a private person’s home.
There wasn't the same taboo about writing
in personal space like there is today.
I doubt any of us would be too happy
if somebody came into our living room
and wrote a message such as this.
The bottom graffiti shows us
that the Pompeiians themselves
had a keen awareness
of how many graffiti covered their walls.
It says, "Oh wall, I'm amazed
you haven't fallen down
holding up so many scribblings."
This message was repeated
several times throughout Pompeii.
This particular one comes
from the amphitheater,
which is the space
in which the gladiators would fight.
Now, most graffiti in Pompeii
were scratched as I mentioned,
but some were written
with perishable materials
like charcoal and chalk.
These graffiti are the subject
of my present research,
and they've been almost totally
ignored by modern scholars
in part because very few of them
survived to this day.
This is a shame,
as these graffiti
are often more flourishing,
inventive and elegant
than their inscribed counterparts.
It was far easier to draw
on top of the wall plaster
than to inscribe into it.
Now here's an example
of one of these graffiti.
This one was written on one
of the gates leading out of the city,
and it was likely made with chalk
or maybe even just a clod of earth.
It says, "Victor
with Phyloterus everywhere."
You can see the very elegant Roman cursive
in which this message was written.
Can you trace the large flourishes
on the V, Y and R letters?
The author included a playful branch
to the right to complete the message.
Now, just above this one
was a graffito made in charcoal.
This time the name Victor,
with a flourishing V.
And right below it, a portrait,
maybe of Victor himself.
We can just make out the right side
of his face, his eye and his nose.
Now, I'm interested in ancient aesthetics.
What does the way the graffito was written
tell us about the person who wrote it
and their motivations?
Now, here's a graffito you don't need
to know Latin to understand.
This one was inscribed into one
of the bathhouses of the city.
Can you read it?
How about now?
That's right.
This was originally written upside down.
Now we don't know if the author wrote it
upside down while standing right side up
or if they twisted their body
to write it upside down.
But either way it shows us the playfulness
of so many of the Roman graffiti.
Have you figured out what it says?
What if I do this?
This was an alphabet.
It's the Latin alphabet interspersed
forwards and backwards.
So it starts with A,
then it goes to X, which is the last
letter of the Roman alphabet,
then B,
then U, which is the second to last,
then C, then T,
which is the third to last,
and so on and so forth.
So we have the alphabet
written upside down
and interspersed forwards and backwards.
It doesn't get more playful than that.
And we can see a utilitarian message
such as an alphabet
could even be written
with elegant writing.
The C and the D letter tails
are so long, they cross.
For the Pompeiians, it wasn’t enough
to write on the walls.
They wanted to write beautifully.
Now looking at graffiti in isolation
such as this is interesting,
but we can gain so much more
when we examine them in context
to understand how these graffiti
relate to each other
and the places they were written in.
But to do that we're going to have
to travel to ancient Pompeii.
Now I wish we could all go there together.
Instead I'm going to take us
there virtually.
We're going to walk down
one avenue in ancient Pompeii
to find the graffiti
that were once written there
and figure out what
can these graffiti tell us
about life in antiquity
and life in the 21st century.
This is our avenue
that we’ll be walking down,
the Vicolo del Menandro,
a small street in a residential district.
We're one block off
from the main avenue in town,
in between the theater
and the amphitheater.
As we walk down the avenue,
we see many names.
Most of the names are male,
as we believe many more men than women
were literate in ancient Pompeii,
but some female names jump out to us too.
It used to be assumed that very few women
in the ancient world were literate,
but graffiti from Pompeii
have truly complicated that picture.
Amongst all the names,
we see a greeting.
This greeting says,
"Prima sends many
greetings to Secundus."
Now Prima and Secundus
mean first and second in Latin.
So these might be names
or they might be nicknames.
So we have a message
from one person to the other.
Well, why did Prima write her message here
on the facade of the wall plaster?
Well, partly to get
her message to Secundus
and to make sure the rest
of Pompeii could read it.
This is the equivalent
of a tweet or a Snapchat.
Wall posts have been around
for over 2,000 years.
Now we can take a look
at how Prima wrote her message.
She wrote it in Roman cursive,
but we can see it looks a lot different
than the charcoal and chalk
examples I showed earlier.
It's difficult to inscribe
into wall plaster
so some of the letter forms
become economical,
such as the Es which are
underlined on the slide.
They become just two vertical marks.
We can see though that Prima
included an interpunct,
a horizontally centered dot
between the first and second word
and I literally mean first and second.
That's what those words mean in Latin.
This interpunct helped to show
where the first word stopped
and the second word began
and was a mark of elegant writing.
Now, just below this graffito
there were several drawings.
Unfortunately we don't have
these ones today,
but I've drawn them here to show you
what they might have looked like
based on other drawings found at Pompeii.
There were four boars, three birds,
a gladiator, a ship
and a partridge in a pear tree.
I'm kidding about the last one.
Now, scholars such as Katherine Huntley
have used developmental psychology
to propose that some drawings
were the work of children,
but others like these could be
the work of adults, too,
replicating things they'd seen
or heard in picture form.
My point here is that just like the urge
to write on a wall is as old as time,
I believe the urge to doodle
is a feature of the human spirit.
Now, a little bit further down our wall
we might have a reply
from Secundus to Prima.
Again, these might be nicknames,
so we're not sure, but it's possible.
This message says, "Secundus too
greet his Prima everywhere.
I ask, mistress, that you love me."
Now let's look at the way
Secundus wrote his message.
He didn't write it in the Roman
cursive like Prima
and definitely not like
the flourishing cursive we started with.
Instead, he wrote his message
in capital letters
so that Prima and the rest
of Pompeii wouldn't miss it.
And if we look, he accentuated the message
with the box surrounding it
as a way to highlight the message
and to make it look more official
like official inscriptions.
If we look at the way
Secundus spelled his words,
he left off the [As] on most of the words,
likely because they weren't
being pronounced at the time.
If you've ever said "gonna"
instead of "going to,"
you're familiar with this
sort of phenomenon.
Just below this message,
Secundus wrote two further greetings.
Unfortunately we don't have
drawings of these ones,
but the excavator who discovered them
said that they were written
by the same person
and using the same instrument.
So they probably looked
pretty similar to the message above.
And these ones say,
"Secundus greets his Prima, Secundus."
"Secundus greets his Prima."
Can we just feel Secundus's love
through these messages?
Again, Secundus has left off the A
in spelling Prima's name,
all three times.
Probably because it wasn't pronounced.
I tell my Latin students,
"Don't be afraid of making mistakes.
Even the Romans made them."
Now, why did Secundus and Prima
write these messages to one another?
Well, partly it was to get
their messages to the other person.
But I believe there's something else
going on here too.
Part of it is to take part
in this thrill of discovery.
How many of us have left
a sticky note for somebody
or put a note in a lunch box
or written on somebody's
social media to find later?
Oh, come on, everybody's
hands should be up.
Right.
You want to get your message
to the other person,
but it's also taking part
in the thrill of discovery,
knowing you're leaving something behind
for somebody to find later.
And I believe that's a motivation
for these greeters in Pompeii.
Now we continue down our walk and we find
more evidence of elegant writing.
Here we have a farewell greeting,
"Veneria, goodbye."
And the ends of the letters
made to look like branches.
Just below it is a graffito
that has stumped scholars.
It doesn't really make sense in Latin.
I believe it was a first attempt
for the graffito above.
Or perhaps somebody was replicating
the elegant graffito above
in rather simpler form,
and they weren’t as effective.
These two graffiti show us the true
elegance that was possible
in some of these Latin graffiti.
As we continue down our avenue,
we end with a graffito
that shows us a group
almost completely left out
of the literary record,
and these are the enslaved.
This graffito says,
"Amianthus, slave of Coelius Caldus,
a clothes washer."
Now, clothes washing was a notoriously
dirty business in antiquity.
One of the materials used
to wash clothes was urine.
While we wish we could know more
about Amianthus's life,
this graffito has at least
given us the name
of one of the many enslaved
whose lives have been lost to history.
We end our tour with one final graffito.
This one says, "On September 3,
Satura was here."
How many of us have seen
a graffito such as this
or such as this
while waiting at the train station
or using the restroom?
Satura could hardly have known
that a destructive
and deadly eruption in 79 AD
would preserve this graffito
and thereby her memory for us today.
The urge to write on the wall,
to leave your name behind
in space and time,
is as old as time.
While I am by no means advocating
that we all go out
and start writing graffiti,
I hope we can consider
what messages we're leaving behind
and what we hope will last
for the next generation.
Thank you
(Applause)